كيف وجدوهم وما هي الدلائل التي ساعدت فرق
البحث للوصول اليهم اسئله كثيره تبادرت
الى الاذهان بعد العثور على اربعه اطفال
تاهوا في غابات الامازون لاكثر من اربعين
يوما الاطفال الاربعه كانوا على متن طائره
برفقه والدتهم حينما تعرضت لحادث ادى
لتحطمها منذ سته اسابيع
السلطات عثرت في البدايه على الطائره وجفت
الام بالاضافه لقبطان الطائره ومساعده دون
ان تجد اثرا للاطفال الذين يبلغ اكبرهم 13
عاما واصغرهم عمره لا يتجاوز العم لكنها
استدلت على موقعهم لاحقا من خلال دلائل
تركها الاطفال تمثلت باثار اقدامهم في
الطين وثمار فاكهه عليها علامات اسنان
بشريه كما وجدوا مقصا بجانبه ربطه شعر
واخيرا وجدوا قطعه من هيكل هاتف ذكي مرميه
على الارض هذه العلامات اعطت الامل
للسلطات بان الاطفال مازالوا احياء ولحقوا
بها حتى وصلوا لمكان وجودهم في النهايه
نجاه الاطفال في تلك الغابات الكثيفه وبعد
كل تلك المده وصفت بالمعجزه خاصه ان
المنطقه تعد موطنا لبعض الحيوانات
المفترسه كالافاعي والنور
[موسيقى]